[Musique]
c'est bien ça le b15 la réunion ça oui
tu as bien fait dit chaque fois qu'il ya
des cas parce que tu as passé quoi pour
se guérir c'est n'importe quoi c'est une
caméra cachée
[Applaudissements]
du coup il apparaît à vrai dire il ya
pas l'entreprise non plus c'est un
canular
quant à piéger ses côtés mme pécresse
c'est vrai ça fait ça fait longtemps et
il s'est hissé au remake et non un
moment j'étais là et tous rue bergère
adéquat ou stress pige j'avais ma grosse
caméra de l'époque ben écoute mon vieux
s'était passé pour moi
tahri a capté mais j'étais au collège
oh oui l'école publique était drôle tout
les matin 6h du mat cinq fois dans la
semaine mais dis toi bien on paye mais
même moi je le fais par mail vous foutez
de ma gueule là c'est moi le pire
c'était les mac
l'usdk le la trigonométrie gounou me dit
ah ah
j'arrive même pas le nom
puis l'inventer ça c'est super utile la
gueule et un angle de rien du tout non
les nombres imaginés s est dit dans le
titre
pour m puce à l'oreille et toi tu vois
rien mais nombre y sont imaginaires on
m'a dit que ça existait alors tu sais
pas ce qu ils sautaient dans le bus il
plonge et iv pour le lait le lait si
génial
le lait des vaches qui sont dégueulasses
la date rue de sèze buvait on n'aide
personne boit du lait si oui à la limite
à revault on a même fait pourrir une
fois pour voir on appelait sa roue
magique pas mais pas menti depuis je
suis né non plus je suis pas content
j'ai des souvenirs je garde des
souvenirs d'avant t4 non parce qu'on
vient de remonter l'âge de 4 ans la
période de gestation chez l'humain ces
neuf mois et c'est pas systématiquement
la femme qui porte l'enfant quand elle
choisit mais tu lui as dit qu'on pouvait
tisser des toiles comme ça non mais ça
tout le monde à ça moi aussi j'ai des
pouvoirs alors toi tu as le sida quoi
mater du capitou non je passe à 11 face
à crach prasad et du lat
c'est du caca
on en a mis dans les arts pour faire
genre c'est un fou oui mais c'est de la
merde
cette accroche les matières fécales
qui sort du cul des gens mais non moins
qu'en chine s'en passer des trucs marron
l'acquis ouaip ans à avoir médecin quand
même écrit qu'apple tes devoirs etc ce
testing il épluché de la merde tu
habites art avec le voc raspes où il
passe pouilles et regarder qui voilà
comment web alors pour le coup là
vraiment amer cette année c'est un
animateur et pendant tout ce temps
talent un truc tellement c'était rémy
alors que rémy s'était clément on a sous
traité comme pour ta meuf
ben c'est pas ta meuf
bon ben c'est pas tout ça on s'est bien
fondu la gueule non va peut-être pas
camper là rien d'autre attend pas
[Musique]
face à lula
retour à la réalité ou cas
bienvenue dans vraiment
[Musique]